you know uh there's this theme that
we've been following in the republican
party over the last many years
allegations are confessions now of
course we're not literally saying it
it's not strictly true
but many of the things that republicans
accuse the left of doing we later find
out they themselves are actually doing
and one of those things is that a trump
endorsed republican has been caught
tampering with voting machines despite
being a big uh
one of the people crying wolf
when it comes to
voter fraud
reuters reports trump-backed michigan
attorney general candidate involved in
voting system breach documents show
this is about the republican nominee for
michigan attorney general his name is
matthew deperno
he led a team that gained unauthorized
access to voting machines while hunting
for evidence to support trump's claims
about election fraud understand that
in searching for evidence of election
fraud
you end up tampering with voting
machines and accessing things that
you're not supposed to
the analysis shows that people working
with matthew diperno examined a vote
tabulator from richfield township a
conservative stronghold of 3 600 people
in michigan
the richfield security breach is one of
four similar incidents being
investigated by the current ag democrat
dana nessel under state law it is a
felony to seek or provide
unauthorized access to voting
deperno did not respond to a request for
comment
the involvement of a republican attorney
general nominee in a voting system
breach comes amid a national effort by
backers of trump's fraud falsehoods to
win state offices that could prove
critical in deciding any future
contestant election understand the what
what this is okay
matthew diperno is running for attorney
general
were he to win that race
he would be involved generally speaking
in supervising future elections in
michigan and at least theoretically in
prosecuting real instances of voter
fraud election tampering etc
and he himself now has been allegedly
caught
tampering with voting machines
and accessing things he is not supposed
to have access to
and all of it was done because he's
looking
for voter fraud that actually doesn't
exist
here is a clip of donald trump a few
months ago very strongly praising matt
diperno check this out
somebody said well he's very tough
that's what you need
who was putting his life and reputation
on the line right matt diperno
after the 2020 election
matt led the explosive investigation to
what happened in antrim county where
among other irregularities
votes were switched by mistake
and had to be corrected none of it
happened okay so anyway the guy trump
really likes to investigate
all of the fraud done against trump is
now accused of tampering with voting
machines you really can't script this
stuff you truly cannot
let's hope this guy doesn't win because
if he does then the temperer will be in
charge of prosecuting the voter fraud
that may or may not take place that
doesn't sound very good